je voudrais maintenant vous présenter un
document exceptionnel il s'agit d'une
oeuvre collective réalisée par une
équipe d'une dizaine d'une quinzaine
plus exactement de cinéastes travaillant
clandestinement entre le 16 et le 26
août 1944 dans paris pour filmer sa
libération alors avant de voir ce
document pierre miquel vous êtes
historien tout le monde vous connais
vous connaissez particulièrement cette
période de notre histoire
en quoi ce document qui est présenté par
l'ina aujourd'hui et qui fait 32 minutes
et il est exceptionnel il est
exceptionnel parce que c'est l'oeuvre
collective de cameramen résistants qui
sont groupés et à qui on a confié enfin
une maison d'actualité a confié des
caméras et les reprêtera lp pellicule
pour qu'ils éclatent dans paris et qui
constitua une espèce de reportages
improvisé sur les combats c'est donc des
images prises sur le vif et qu'on n'a
jamais vus on les voit retrouver on les
a retrouvés maintenant à la cinémathèque
de l'ina on les a vus passer dans les
actualités de la libération à paris et
puis c'est tout depuis personne ne les a
jamais vus alors c'est évidemment une
première et c'est évidemment intéressant
alors que montrent ces images d'abord
les allemands qui s'en vont c'est de
nature à réjouir les parisiens mais on
les avait jamais vus à l'image et on les
voit de près on les voit de près et puis
il ya plein de détails qui sortent par
exemple y avait une barricade à côté du
magasin de mon père place saint michel
j'ai revu cette barque avec les gens qui
sont en train d'apporter les pavés pour
la construire
et puis il ya des gens qui tirent sur
les quais et lord tout d'un coup vous
voyez des gens qui ont l'air d'être à la
fête comme si la libération était fait
un moment après ça c'est bien le climat
de l'époque tout le monde se cache pas
ce qu'on se met à tirer otis le quoi
alors pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des
batailles sur les quais on vous le dit
jamais c'est parce qu'à des convois
allemands qu'ils aient circulé que les
résistants veulent tard et elle rit tir
de dans les allemands s'arrête riposte
et puis repartent mais ça dure très peu
de temps et ça fait beaucoup de morts
alors on peut ajouter que la voix qu'on
entend c'est celle de pierre blanche
alors pour l'aïe pour les plus jeunes il
faut peut-être si tu es fier à ses
grands acteurs de cette période un
comédien immense dont la voix était à
l'époque très connue parce qu'il avait
fait des films d'un grand succès
et qui avait une voix très basse très
grave qui convenait bien l'événement et
qui a salué à sa manière la libération
de paris alors là il y en a quand même
un doute il faut parler vous savez c'est
gilbert l'aria gars parce que l'art yaga
keita cameraman de la transversale quand
elsa illégal du réalisateur a été blessé
au genou dont il est en train de filmer
un char de leclerc aux champs elysées en
plein combat
anne obus allemands arrivent léandri
blessé gravement et l'aria gaouchi et
l'aria gaal a été dans cette équipe de
gens qui ont filmé d'une mare prenant
des risques énormes
les combats de la libération à la pierre
miquel j'ajoute simplement veut donc que
cette 32800 une cassette qui est
aujourd'hui vendu dans tous les maisons
spécialisées en france qu'à celles de li
na donc sur la libération de paris
on va revoir tout de suite un extrait de
4 minutes 30 je vous propose de le
regarder vous allez voir c'est vraiment
passionnant 19 août 1944
les voitures allemandes s'agit
également pas
l'armée de faire des ménages à la glotte
de voix
m
répartis d'une retraite ou un mauvais
coup et soudain avec nos premiers boucle
la décision est prise je n'en finis et
un bruit court de bouche à oreille aux
armes citoyens
sauf le sent armé se trouvait désarmée
le secours
et soudain le coeur même de paris
commence à battre et à se battre pour la
cité berceau de la bile rendre notre
dame il fallait saint louis la
préfecture de police et le produit
passion de la résistance les allemands
ont fini par comprendre
ils savent maintenant qu'on ne laissera
pas partir sans leur dire adieu et même
on retiendra quelques uns d'entre eux en
souvenir à travers les gouttes de la
bataille les services organisent dans
l'hôtel de ville les parisiennes sont à
leur poste et l'activité des machines à
écrire et pose dans les bureaux au bruit
des mitrailleuses
l'avis prononcé avec des pistolets
presque à main vie se poursuit avec les
armes prises à l'ennemi ses belles
s'agit son premier char il n'a pas
d'adversaire et une saison séries
paris roman sa mémoire toujours vivons
le grand geste instinctif de sa défense
pour les oppresseurs paris construire
bagdad
on abat des arbres on arrache les pavés
qu'on avait perdu l'habitude l'animation
désemparé incendies les passions qui
n'osent pas enlever et à garçon mon
frère et redouble
l ensemble quand la ville dans les tours
de notre dame des musiciens se sont
retrouvés
il faut attaquer au fusil
d'un point de vue
quel canton de chauny aisne at-elle
d'olive et là dans la lueur des torches
ou 8 avec paris la dernière nuit d'un
front chmakh de quatre ans et la
kommandantur de l'opéra est attaquée à
son tour il a lu tout chaude à travers
une place sur les avenues les chartes
manoeuvrer toutes les armes tonnent de
la boi libération
devant une première vouloir cette
libération et en cherchant dans la ville
vibre pour la première fois depuis
quatre ans migros français par le france
et femmes
sauf qu'ici il se faisait siffler ou en
paris lever debout france libérée et qui
a su le faire de ses mains
non je ne dissimule rompt pas cette
émotion enfants
lesca déjà dans son bras
les peuples de palet est bon et jolie
samedi d'un ciseau après lyon de
bataille et angoisse c'est la journée du
triomphe et d'incertitudes
m
là